these are three of the men who look set
to shape afghanistan's future
taliban supreme leader haibatullah
akanzada an elusive figure rarely seen
in public
the group's co-founder and political
chief abdul ghani
the son of the one-eyed cleric who once
led the taliban when it was toppled in
2001.
the most prominent of the three will be
mullah barada pictured here signing a
peace deal with the united states last
year
released from a pakistani jail in 2018
he's been a key figure in planning the
taliban's return
a moment captured by this footage from
sunday of taliban forces in the
presidential palace
the question now though is will this new
chance at power bring new ideas
or a return to the old brutality of the
past where women in particular suffered
initial signs have caused concern
at the moment in kabul you have women
staying at home
they are preparing for
a disappearance i guess
a disappearance from public life has
happened when the taliban controlled the
country they are liars they are
murderers and they are drug dealers i
can't see and most afghan people
themselves can't see that there's going
to be any change at all it really is a
back to the future situation
sky news's alex crawford was last month
given exclusive access to an afghan army
base captured by the taliban in central
wardak province
a trove of weapons also seized
some look at how the militants then went
on to conquer the whole country so
quickly as a sign of change
[Music]
with the taliban showing a willingness
to work with other ethnic groups outside
their pashtun heartland in the south
they have become very savvy politically
very savvy they know
they have been interacting with
international audiences now for 20 years
the last taliban regime it had
absolutely no exposure at all the only
exploit it had was with the pakistani
officials but they also had exposure to
foreign terrorists the september the
11th attacks on the united states
directed from afghanistan by al qaeda
ties between that group and the taliban
run deep
the hope is that the taliban leadership
will restrain any terrorist activities
if they don't us-led troops now on route
out may be ordered to return
debra haynes sky news